[Music]
world's most famous 29 year old
congresswoman Alexandria Kazuya Cortez
is facing new allegations cite that she
violated campaign finance law according
to a newly filed FEC complaint the
congresswoman and her chief of staff
operated in an illegal subsidy scheme
they ran a network of interconnected
political action committees the
complaint says this allowed her to raise
more money than she would have been
allowed to legally well Sir Francis is a
Fox Business anchor co-host of outnumber
too frequent guests in the show and very
good at detail so we've asked you to
come on sale and explain what this
complaint says well I read the complaint
and in the way it reads it's actually a
very clever scheme it looks like they
set up a company and you could be sort
of a venture investor in this company
and they said it was going to be like
the uber of political campaigns so
anyone could you know kind of come up
and start their campaign and you could
get political services for way below
market price the problem is that the
company went out of business it seems
from the complaint that's how it reads
and this is all alleged but the company
basically spent most of its money on on
her campaign the investors investors
never got anything back they just helped
her campaign so you know if you think
about that in the worst light it sounds
like if you were a finance smart money
guy which her chief of staff who you saw
in that photo is a tech
multi-millionaire I mean I'm sure your
chief of staff is also super wealthy but
I don't know how common that is but
anyway he's good with money and he you
know set up this company now is it
illegal who knows as I've said before
the people who write the laws about
campaign finance are these very crooked
politicians who are trying to hang on to
power and they're the ones that write
the laws so I don't know if it's illegal
there you know it's if the complaint was
brought by a conservative group and
that's her defense she says this is the
right attacking her we'll see how the
investigation goes but I think the main
point is that she was supposed to be
about getting money out of politics and
about transparency where's the money
coming from and what we're seeing is
more and more evidence that she's got
all kinds of money that helped her get
elected
and it was very murky and shady there
was nothing transparent about it
everything is irony that's what I'm
starting to suspect in hypocrisy in
hypocrisy hypocrisy just abounding
everywhere so definitely keep an eye on
this one you remember last time she had
set up a limited liability company yes
so that you couldn't look at how the
money was being spent we want to be fair
let's see how these investigations turn
out but they seem to at the very least
you know be that dark money that she
talks about being evil and get it rid of
the dark money unless it's I guess
helping her campaign I don't know
exactly right the socialist sets up
great yeah I hate it they're everywhere
most of Frances you were not one of them
great to see you tonight thank you
what's on its final exam tomorrow night
Thursday night don't miss that I'm
studying now wait to talk words thank
you